well the Sudanese Community here in the
UK is getting increasingly worried about
friends um literally let's go straight
to the commons and neverminder Mitchell
now there he is family member
ten days ago Fierce fighting broke out
in cartoon it has since spring
and other Sudanese cities
as members of this house will know a
violent past struggle is ongoing between
the Sudanese Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces
Madame Deputy speaker the situation in
Sudan is extremely grave more than 427
people have been killed including five
Aid workers over 3 700 people have been
injured
before this violence began the
humanitarian situation in Sudan was
already deteriorating we now estimate
that approximately 16 million people a
third of the Sudanese population are in
need of humanitarian assistance
these numbers I regret to inform the
house are likely to rise significantly
well the paramilitary rapid support
forces announced a 72-hour ceasefire
from 0-500 hours London time on the 21st
of April to Mark the holy Festival of
Eid it did not hold
given the rapidly deteriorating security
situation the government took the
difficult decision to evacuate all
British Embassy staff and their
dependents to fulfill our duty to
protect our staff as their employer
this highly complex operation was
completed yesterday
the operation involved more than 1200
Personnel from 16 Air Assault Brigade
The Royal Marines and the Royal Air
Force
I know the house will join me in
commending the brilliant work of our
colleagues in the ministry of Defense as
well as The Bravery of our service men
and women for completing this operation
successfully amidst extremely dangerous
circumstances
I also want to pay tribute to our
International partners for their ongoing
cooperation in aligning our rescue
responses and I want to express my
admiration for the work of the crisis
center in the foreign office where over
200 officials are working 24 7 and
seamlessly across government to
coordinate the UK response
Deputy speaker the Safety and Security
of British Nationals continues to be our
utmost priority our ability to support
British Nationals has not been impacted
by the relocation of British Embassy
staff the evacuation team will continue
to operate from a neighboring country
alongside the foreign office in London
which is working throughout the day and
night to support British Nationals and
push for a ceasefire in Sudan
we are asking all British Nationals in
Sudan to register their presence with us
the roughly 2 000 British Nationals
registered with us already are being
sent sometimes with great difficulty at
least daily updates by text and email
this step helps enable us to remain in
contact with them whilst we find a safe
passage from Sudan
movement around the capital remains
extremely dangerous and no evacuation
option comes without grave risk to life
Khartoum airport is out of action energy
supplies are disrupted food and water
are becoming increasingly scarce
internet and telephone networks are
becoming difficult to access
we continue to advise all British
Nationals in Sudan to stay indoors
wherever possible we recognize
circumstances will vary in different
locations across Sudan so we are now
asking British Nationals to exercise
their own judgment about their
circumstances including whether to
relocate but they do so at their own
risk
ending the violence Madame Deputy
speaker is the single most important
action we can take to guarantee the
safety of British Nationals and everyone
in Sudan the Prime Minister the foreign
secretary the Secretary of State for
defense and I have been in continuous
contact with allies and with key
Regional Partners since the outbreak of
violence to agree a joint approach to
both evacuation and de-escalation of
vans
over the weekend the Prime Minister
spoke to his counterparts including
Egyptian president sisi and the
president of Djibouti
the foreign secretary was in contact
with the Kenyan president the U.S
Secretary of State and foreign Ministers
of France Germany the UAE Saudi Arabia
Djibouti Sweden turkey Cyprus and the EU
High representative for foreign and
security policy the defense secretary
engaged with counterparts in Djibouti
the U.S France and Egypt I have spoken
to the African Union and the prime
minister in Exile of Sudan upon whom so
many hopes rested further escalation of
this conflict particularly if it spills
over into neighboring countries would be
disastrous as we continue to make clear
there must be a genuine and Lasting
ceasefire
Madam Deputy speaker we undertake to
keep the house informed as the situation
develops today all MPS will receive a
second dear colleague letter from the
foreign secretary and myself this will
hopefully help to answer a number of
frequently asked questions to assist
honorable and right honorable members in
supporting their constituents Madam
Deputy speaker I will continue to be in
close contact with the has and provide
updates wherever possible in the coming
days I commend this statement to the
house